depuis maintenant plusieurs mois vous
n'avez certainement pas échappé à la
déferlante des images qui sont générés
par des intelligences artificielles des
IA qu'il s'agisse de Dali de mi-journée
ou encore de stables diffusion il existe
maintenant plusieurs programmes
extrêmement efficaces capables de créer
de toutes pièces une image à partir
d'une description et ce que font ces Ia
ça n'est pas du google images elles ne
vont pas chercher une image existante
mais elle produisent des images
nouvelles qui n'existent pas et qu'elle
crée à la demande il peut s'agir de
photographies de peinture ou d'art
numérique et on peut même parfois
spécifier le type d'objectif photo ou le
style du peintre que l'on souhaite
imiter on appelle ces types
d'algorithmes des iaténerratives car
elles sont capables de créer du contenu
à la demande en intégrant à la
conception une part d'aléatoire de façon
à pouvoir obtenir plein de variations à
partir de la même demande si vous avez
essayé ces images génératives vous avez
peut-être été comme moi ébahi par leur
capacité à faire quelque chose qui
semble être impossible il y a seulement
quelques années ça paraît presque
magique tellement ça fonctionne bien
mais au fait comment ça fonctionne
vraiment et bien c'est ce qu'on va voir
ensemble aujourd'hui
[Musique]
alors commençons par quelques remarques
de base sur la terminologie ce qu'on
appelle l'intelligence artificielle
c'est un domaine au contour un peu flou
on peut dire que son objectif est de
réaliser à l'aide de machines des tâches
traditionnellement réalisées par des
humains et dont on estime qu'elle
requiert de l'intelligence sans trop
préciser le sens qu'on donne à ce terme
au sein de l'IA il y a un champ de
recherche assez bien identifié qu'on
appelle le machine learning ou
apprentissage automatique l'idée est de
s'attaquer notamment à des questions
d'IA en mettant au point des algorithmes
capables d'apprendre et qui réalise leur
apprentissage à partir de données
auxquelles ils ont accès et dans le
machine learning il y a le Deep learning
et ça c'est l'idée d'utiliser une classe
assez spécifique d'algorithmes que sont
les réseaux de neurones profonds et qui
ont connu un énorme succès depuis une
dizaine d'années
aujourd'hui quand on utilise le terme Ia
il s'agit presque systématiquement de
Deep learning dans cette approche est
efficace alors je vais pas évoquer ici
les principes de base du Deep learning
j'avais déjà fait toute une vidéo sur le
sujet il y a quelques temps et je vous
invite à aller la voir si ça vous
intéresse quand on parle d'algorithme
capable d'apprendre ça fonctionne
souvent selon le même principe imaginez
qu'on veut créer un algorithme qui soit
capable de reconnaître ce qu'il y a sur
une image
on veut un programme à qui on donne une
image en entrée et qui produisent un mot
en sortie et on veut que cet algorithme
réponde chat sur cette image sur
celle-ci voiture etc pour réaliser ça on
va utiliser ce qu'on appelle de
l'apprentissage supervisé au départ
notre algorithme va être
ignorant et répondre n'importe quoi
quand on lui présente une image et puis
on va lui fournir une grande base de
données d'exemple c'est-à-dire des
milliers d'images de chats de voitures
de tasse etc avec à chaque fois la
réponse qu'on attendrait lui en
utilisant ces exemples l'algorithme va
peu à peu ajuster ces paramètres pour
s'améliorer il va apprendre jusqu'à être
capable de réaliser lui-même le travail
de façon suffisamment correcte on dit
alors que l'algorithme aura été entraîné
et on pourra commencer à l'utiliser
alors ça semble un peu magique présenté
comme ça de penser qu'un algorithme peut
reconnaître des images et associer les
bons mots mais il faut voir que tout ce
que fait l'algorithme c'est de manipuler
des nombres tout se fait via des
opérations mathématiques par exemple sur
la classification des images voici
comment on fait en pratique on définit
d'abord un nombre fini de catégories
chat voiture tasse etc et on leur
attribue des numéros 1 2 3 on peut faire
disons 1000 catégories et à chaque image
de notre base de données on va associer
une de ces 1000 catégories et pour
l'image elle-même on va aussi la
représenter comme une série de nombres
une image 600 par 600 ce sont 360 000
pixels chacun de ces pixels va être codé
en rouge vert bleu donc il faut trois
nombres par pixels et au total je peux
décrire complètement mon image avec un
peu plus d'un million de nombres
ces algorithmes de classification
d'image fonctionnent extrêmement bien
avec des performances proches de celles
des humains alors intuitivement on se
dit que ça n'est pas très très éloigné
de ce qu'on voudrait faire pour générer
des nouvelles images pour classifier des
images existantes en entrée x on a des
images et en sortie y un mot qui les
décrit et une base de données pour
réaliser l'entraînement on a qu'à
entraîné un algorithme du même genre sur
la même base de données mais à l'envers
on lui donne un mot en entrée et on
attend qu'il produisent une image en
sortie facile non
et ben non ça ne marche pas comme ça il
y a plusieurs raisons à ça dans une
tâche de prédiction comme la
classification des images on donne en
entrée beaucoup d'informations indés
centaines de milliers de pixels et en
sortie on récupère quelque chose de très
limité juste le numéro de catégorie par
exemple l'algorithme de classification
réalise en quelque sorte de la synthèse
d'information ici c'est l'inverse qu'on
veut on donne très peu de choses en
entrée disons juste un mot et on
s'attend en sortie à récupérer une image
entière qui contient donc beaucoup plus
d'informations que ce qu'on a mis au
départ ça peut pas marcher avec un
simple algorithme d'apprentissage
supervisé
alors en fait si on peut essayer mais ce
qui risque de se passer c'est que notre
algorithme une fois entraîné chaque fois
qu'on lui demande une image de chat il
va nous ressortir exactement l'image de
chat qu'il avait dans sa base de données
ou bien une sorte de moyenne de toutes
les images de chats qu'on lui a fourni
et c'est pas ça qu'on veut
l'autre aspect important c'est qu'on
veut que notre algorithme de génération
d'image est une part d'aléatoire si je
lui demande 50 fois un chat et bien je
veux qu'il me produit 50 images
différentes pas 50 fois le même chat
généré ça n'est pas la même chose que
prédire donc vous voyez que pour créer
des images à partir d'un texte prendre
une approche traditionnelle de
prédiction par apprentissage supervisé
et bien ça ne va pas marcher il faut
faire autrement alors voyons comment en
2014 une première façon de faire assez
efficace a été proposée par une équipe
de l'Université de Montréal ça s'appelle
les réseaux adversariaux génératifs Gan
en anglais alors qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire ce truc pour voir ça prenons un
problème plus simple que celui que j'ai
évoqué imaginons pour commencer que je
veuille uniquement créer des images de
chats je dispose d'une grande base de
données d'images de chat je veux juste
être capable d'en créer plein d'autres
de nouvelles qui n'existent pas
initialement dans la base et qui
ressemble bien à des chats alors pour ça
je vais entraîner non pas un mais deux
réseaux de neurones le premier on va
l'appeler le faussaire il aura pour rôle
de générer aléatoirement des images à
partir d'une série de paramètres et le
deuxième on va l'appeler l'expert et sa
tâche va être simple si on lui présente
une image il va devoir apprendre à
reconnaître si l'image est une vraie
image de chat qui provient de la base de
données ou bien une image inventée par
le faussaire rappelez-vous le principe
de l'apprentissage au début ces
algorithmes sont mauvais le faussaire
quand on lui demande de produire une
image de chat et bien il va produire des
images de ce genre du bruit complet et
l'expert quand on lui présente deux
images en lui demandant quelle est la
vraie au début il va répondre au pif et
puis à force d'essai et d'erreur s'est
réseau vont progresser car à chaque fois
on leur donne le résultat de leurs
performances on indique au faussaire
s'il a réussi à berner l'expert et
l'expert lui c'est s'il a correctement
discriminé les images qu'on lui présente
donc au départ l'expert va assez vite
apprendre à reconnaître les vrais chats
des fausses images qui sont initialement
assez pourris et puis peu à peu le
faussaire va progresser et faire des
images qui seront de mieux en mieux et
ça va forcer l'expert à améliorer son
niveau et en laissant les deux
s'entraîner ensemble suffisamment
longtemps on finira si tout va bien par
avoir un faux serre capable de produire
des images très semblables ou vraies et
un expert qui aura bien du mal à faire
la différence ce principe d'entraînement
on l'appelle adversarial puisque les
deux réseaux neurones s'affrontent et
progressent de concerts c'est comme si
vous demandiez à deux joueurs de foot de
s'entraîner ensemble à l'un fait le
tireur de penalty et donc le gardien
avec l'idée qu'ils vont conjointement
progresser ces réseaux adversariaux
génératifs gagne existe maintenant
depuis plusieurs années et vous les avez
certainement vu à l'oeuvre si vous
connaissez le site 10 personnes dans
notre exist
sur ce site on a des réseaux qui ont été
entraînés à partir de photos de visage
et qui sont donc excellents à inventer
de nouveaux visages de toutes pièces
alors il y a parfois des défauts mineurs
mais dans l'ensemble c'est quand même
assez bluffant
dans le même genre vous avez aussi pour
les voitures
iscard dans notre existent et pour les
maisons this House de notre existent
ce type d'algorithmes est donc très
efficace pour produire des images d'un
type donné et fixé à l'avance si vous
l'entraînez sur des voitures il vous
fera des voitures si vous l'entraînez
sur des chats il vous fera des chats
mais vous voyez qu'on n'est pas encore
au stade où on peut rentrer librement du
texte et avoir une image qui mélange
plusieurs concepts on va y venir mais
avant ça prenons un peu de recul et
essayons de comprendre la différence
entre ce que font les réseaux génératifs
et l'apprentissage supervisé qu'on a vu
avant celui qui permet par exemple de
classifier des images dans
l'apprentissage supervisé on donne X en
entrée et on attend que l'algorithme
nous préalise y en sortie et pour ça on
lui donne plein d'exemples de XY avec
les réseaux génératifs on donne plein de
X en entrée par exemple des images de
chats et on dit à l'algorithme bah vas-y
donne moi d'autres
essayons de se représenter la différence
en imaginant qu'il n'y ait que deux
dimensions par exemple si X et Y sont
chacun de simples nombres réels dans ce
cas on peut représenter chaque exemple X
Y de la base de données comme un point
dans un diagramme en deux dimensions
dans l'apprentissage supervisé on veut
que l'algorithme puisse prédire y à
partir de X donc en gros on veut que
notre algorithme arrive à faire une
sorte de régression qui lui permet de
deviner à peu près la valeur de y si on
lui présente une nouvelle valeur de x
qu'il n'a jamais vu dans la base ok
maintenant comment ça se passe pour un
algorithme génératif à qui on demande de
construire de nouveaux exemples à partir
d'une liste de X imaginez que dans mon
cas X soit en deux dimensions donc
décrit par deux nombres alors deux c'est
pas beaucoup tout à l'heure une image on
dit que c'était un million de valeur
mais nous on va regarder que deux
appelons les X1 X2 donc ma base
d'exemple c'est une liste de valeurs X1
X2 imaginez que je représente chaque
exemple dans un diagramme et que
j'obtienne ça ou bien ça
manifestement il se passe quelque chose
dans mon premier cas on voit que tous
les exemples sont groupés dans un
certain coin et dans mon second cas on
voit qu'il y a quand même comme une
structure sous-jacente si on me
présentait une base de données de ce
genre je serai capable de dire quelque
chose d'intéressant sur la façon dont
sont répartis les exemples sur leur
distribution ils sont pas quelconque ils
ne sont qu'une petite partie de l'espace
total des possibilités
et avec les images de chat c'est pareil
ok il y a un million de dimensions donc
c'est dur à visualiser mais les images
de chats ne sont pas des images
quelconque dans l'espace immense de
toutes les images possibles et
imaginables les images de chats ne sont
qu'une minuscule région et ce qu'on veut
faire c'est en savoir plus sur cette
région car si on arrive à dire des trucs
intelligents sur la manière dont sont
distribués les exemples d'une base de
données on sera capable de faire de
l'échantillonnage c'est à dire de
produire de nouveaux points qui ont de
bonnes chances d'être du même genre dans
mes exemples en deux dimensions si je
considère par exemple ces points ci ou
cela dans le diagramme d'à côté et bien
ce sont des points qui n'étaient pas
dans les bases initiales mais dont on a
bien envie de penser qu'ils auraient pu
y figurer qu'ils ont certainement les
mêmes caractéristiques qui nous
intéressent
et pareil pour mes chats je voudrais
être capable de créer une image qui soit
nouvelle et que j'aille la prendre dans
la sous-région qui contient toutes les
images de chats et vous voyez que cette
gymnastique est différente de
l'apprentissage supervisé on ne fait pas
de la prédiction au sens où on me
donnerait X et où je ferai y non ici on
a ce qu'on appelle de l'apprentissage
non supervisé l'apprentissage non
supervisé c'est quand on a des données
dans notre base de données qui ne sont
pas séparées en X et Y ce sont juste des
exemples X et qu'on essaye de comprendre
comment ces X se sont distribués dans
l'espace de toutes les possibilités de
façon à pouvoir par exemple en générer
de nouveaux par échantillonnage
évidemment à nouveau d'une part ça ne se
passe pas dans un espace à deux
dimensions et d'autre part les régions
qu'on cherche à identifier n'ont pas des
formes simples ça se voit très bien par
exemple par le fait que la moyenne de
deux images de chat ne donne pas
forcément une bonne image de chat mais
si vous arrivez à correctement
caractériser la région dans laquelle se
trouve toutes les images de chats de
votre base initiale vous pouvez avec une
certaine confiance échantillonnée de
nouvelles images en allant chercher au
même endroit bien donc générer de
nouvelles images ça n'est pas une tâche
d'apprentissage supervisé mais c'est une
tâche d'apprentissage non supervisée et
on l'a dit les réseaux adversariaux
gagne marchent bien pour ça mais ne
fonctionne que si on donne plein
d'exemples en entrée et il faut le faire
pour chaque type de catégorie qu'on veut
générer des chats des voitures des
appartements etc les applications sont
donc limitées et ça explique qu'on n'est
pas vu de choses très spectaculaires
depuis 10 personnes dans un autre
existent sauf depuis l'été 2022 avec
l'apparition de Dali 2 et stable
diffusion qui n'utilise pas vegan et
donc voyons maintenant cette nouvelle
technique qui fait fureur en ce moment
les algorithmes de diffusion
[Musique]
avant de voir comment les algorithmes de
diffusion sont capables de créer des
images en prenant un texte libre comme
point de départ voyons déjà comment il
fonctionne sur la même tâche que celle
des Ganes générer plus d'image d'un type
donné le principe de base est assez
simple et ça semble presque miraculeux
que ça fonctionne vous allez voir
imaginez une image de chat je peux
essayer de dégrader cette image en la
Bruant alors c'est facile je génère une
image qui est du pur bruit c'est-à-dire
que chaque pixel a une couleur
totalement aléatoire et puis je mélange
les deux images avec certaines
proportions disons 95% de chats et 5% de
bruit
j'obtiens une image de chat légèrement
dégradée et ce que je vais faire c'est
d'abord une étape d'apprentissage
supervisé je vais entraîner un réseau de
neurones à desbruité les images c'est à
dire que je crée une base de données
avec en entrée des images bruitées et en
sortie les images d'origine et je donne
ça à mon réseau pour lui apprendre à
enlever le bruit ici il doit enlever 5%
de bruit
et ce qui est intéressant c'est que je
peux faire ça avec différents niveaux de
bruit par exemple je peux brouter une
image à 45% et à 50%, et entraîner mon
réseau à retirer 5% de bruit pour passer
de 50 à 45 et pareil avec 90 et 95 si je
donc si j'ai une base de données
d'images de chat je peux toutes les
bruités à plein de niveaux différents et
entraîner mon réseau avec et à la fin de
son entraînement mon algorithme sera
devenu super fort à débruiter des images
de chats maintenant une fois que mon
algorithme de débroutage est entraîné
imaginez que je lui donne une image qui
soit 100% de bruit j'ai tiré chaque
pixel au hasard et que je lui dise bah
vas-y débrouilles là progressivement
retire 5% de bruit puis encore 5% puis
encore 5%. qu'est-ce qui va se passer et
bien comme mon algorithme aura été
uniquement entraîné à débruiter des
images de chats il va progressivement
m'inventer une image de chat à partir du
bruit initial et cette image ne sera
aucune des images de la base initiale ce
sera une nouvelle image il va en quelque
sorte halluciner une image de chat à
partir du pur bruit qu'on lui donne en
entrée
et en faisant ça notre algorithme fait
de l’échantillonnage parmi la
distribution de toutes les images de
chats possibles et imaginables on tire
un bruit au hasard et il nous fait une
image de chat avec cet échantillonnage
est donc une forme d'apprentissage non
supervisée de la distribution des images
de chats
cette idée de génération à partir d'un
débruitage progressif c'est ça qu'on
appelle les méthodes de diffusion alors
la technique a été proposée il y a
quelques années déjà mais elle vient de
connaître une accélération grâce à de
nombreuses améliorations récentes alors
à ce stade de ma description ce type
d'approche ne fait pas mieux que les
Ganes si vous faites ça avec des images
de voitures au lieu d'images de chat et
bien vous allez entraîner un réseau de
débruitage qui aura la capacité à
halluciner des images de voitures donc
on peut générer des images d'un certain
type à condition d'en avoir donné
suffisamment d'exemples en entrée et de
refaire l'entraînement à chaque fois
mais il est possible d’étendre le
concept pour le rendre plus polyvalent
vous souvenez du problème de
classification d'image on a une grande
base de données d'images et chacune est
associée à une classe chat voiture
visage etc ce qu'on peut faire c'est
traiter tout ça d'un coup pour ça on va
bruité ces images et les donner à notre
algorithme pour qu'il apprenne à les
débruiter mais en lui spécifiant à
chaque fois la catégorie à laquelle
appartient chaque image
l'algorithme de débruitage sera ainsi
capable de s'ajuster en fonction de la
catégorie c'est un principe qu'on
appelle le conditionnement on va
conditionner notre débruitage par la
catégorie de l'image et si on fait ça
avec une base de données suffisamment
grande une fois l'entraînement terminé
on aura un algorithme capable
d'alluminer une image en étant
conditionné par une classe si on lui dit
voiture il va halluciner une voiture
chat il va halluciner un chat etc alors
c'est bien mais ça n'est pas encore tout
à fait ce qu'on veut ici on est limité
par les catégories qui ont été choisies
au départ pour classifier les images or
vous voyez que dans Dali 2 ou stable
diffusion on peut entrer librement du
texte un faire des phrases des
descriptions alors comment on procède et
bien il va falloir faire appel à
certains algorithmes de traitement du
langage naturel comme ceux que
j'évoquais dans ma vidéo sur le sujet et
notamment les algorithmes permettant de
faire ce qu'on appelle du plongement en
betting en anglais l'idée du plongement
c'est de partir d'un mot ou d'une phrase
et de lui associer une série de nombres
qui en quelque sorte représente
numériquement son sens sa signification
mais plonger dans un espace mathématique
abstrait de façon à ce que deux phrases
proches et des plongements qui soient
proches il existe des réseaux neurones
qui peuvent réaliser ces plongements et
si on les utilise avec un algorithme de
diffusion on peut alors utiliser le
plongement pour conditionner le
débrouillage ça marche comme tout à
l'heure mais au lieu d'être conditionné
par une catégorie d'images notre
processus de débruitage sera conditionné
par le plongement de la description de
l'image
donc en pratique on prend toujours des
images mais cette fois accompagnée d'une
description libre par exemple une
légende on calcule le plongement de la
légende et on entraîne notre réseau à
débruiter ces images tout en étant
conditionné par le plongement de la
légende et si on fait ça avec
suffisamment d'images légendées et bien
on obtient un algorithme de génération
d'image à partir d'une description vous
tapez un texte l'algorithme calcul son
plongement il génère ensuite une image
100% brutée et Vala débruiter
progressivement tout en étant
conditionné par le plongement de la
description qu'on a donnée et si tout va
bien et bien l'algorithme va halluciner
une image en prenant comme contexte la
description qu'on a donnée
voici dans les grandes lignes comment
fonctionne les algorithmes de diffusion
comme stable diffusion ou encore Dali 2
bon il y a encore pas mal de subtilités
mais je pense que la vidéo est déjà bien
assez lourde et je vous renvoie au
billet de blog qui accompagnent la vidéo
si vous voulez plus de détails
techniques avant de conclure il y a un
point que je dois quand même évoquer ce
sont les problèmes éthiques et
juridiques posées par ces algorithmes
alors il y a bien sûr la possibilité
qu'ils offrent de créer de fausses
images ayant l'air complètement
plausible donc potentiellement de faire
de la désinformation avec et puis il y a
aussi les questions de propriété
intellectuelle puisque ces algorithmes
ont été entraînés à partir d'images
trouvées sur Internet et qui ne sont pas
forcément libres de droit c'est
particulièrement criant pour les dessins
ou l'art numérique en général puisqu'on
peut demander à l'algorithme d'imiter le
style d'un artiste sans que ce dernier
ait eu son mot à dire ces questions sont
plus complexes qui n'y paraît et je n'ai
pas vraiment les compétences artistiques
ou juridiques pour les traiter
correctement d'autant que les choses
évoluent très très vite et qui aura
certainement des effets de jurisprudence
donc
ces interrogations car on risque
d'entendre parler pas mal de ça
prochainement voilà c'est tout pour
aujourd'hui merci d'avoir suivi cette
vidéo n'hésitez pas à aller voir mes
vidéos connexes sur le Deep learning ou
le traitement du langage abonnez-vous si
ce n'est pas déjà le cas et n'hésitez
pas à venir vérifier régulièrement les
nouvelles vidéos même si YouTube ne
voulait propose plus pour celles et ceux
que ça intéresse j'ai aussi créé
récemment un serveur discord de
communautaire donc n'hésitez pas à le
rejoindre pour venir discuter le lien
est en description et puis sur ce moi je
vous dis à très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos à bientôt
[Musique]